so the Giro is inherently known within
the sport of cycling is one of the most
toughest weeks exactly the most grueling
race and in particular the route for
2017 is very gruesome especially that
last week was a lot of climbing for a
team like like ourselves and I just try
and win the big races is very very
important and I think the traditions
that sort of surround the Giro and all
those sort of nostalgia and all that
historical kind of side foot' need
something is absolutely once time way I
think is that it's one of the biggest
challenges to win the Giro because of
the diversity of the event so you kind
of need a rider who can climb we kind of
need a rider who's resilient to get to
that third week or who can also tie in
traffic and when you put all of those
demands together then really the Tyrael
Conrad is one of the toughest races in
2017 for us I've done the Giro twice
before both in Olympic years actually
and as an 8 7 12 and just really enjoyed
the racing of the style of it there's a
lot more so spontaneous and it's got
around 68 59 favored individual time
college policy is a plus for me
what we're looking for is someone who
can of course January of those top
vampire outputs but we also need them to
be able to get to the physician to
strengthen the first West so we have to
try and tree anchor essentially be able
to use fat as a fuel during the flat
parts of the risk to get them into the
position so that we can sprint when that
sprint line comes off and of course a
lot of that is about training
adaptations will also vote body
composition management and making sure
that would lean but also making sure
that we're fresh when we get for that
last part of the list so that we can
spoon on the road the more times you go
after more that your nutrition and your
weight and the guy and anything's a sexy
rate you need to be able to get you off
to man level but obviously not putting
weight on or losing weight things SS
range has been ideal for that really you
know there's so many different parts to
it you know from the protein sides of
the carbs and you know all the different
gels and yeah and obviously they said
they taste Goods and they're easy to
sort of digest which is the main thing
you train so hard and dedicate your life
to it and you know especially with stage
racing you're really watching what you
eat and in real time get lean and you
know you make a lot of sacrifices and a
lot of time away from friends and family
so when you do get that win this kind of
makes all that worthwhile really
[Music]
you
you